crime and punishment on the street are
plain for all to see online it's much
less visible but according to a new
report it's every bit as financially
damaging the amount of cyber crime is
increasing at such an exponential rate
it almost feels like we're swimming
against the tide it's important for
nations around the world to begin to
track and record the number of cyber
crime incidents they're seeing because
we can't actually address the problem
until we actually know how big the issue
is cybercrime costs two hundred and
sixty six billion pounds each year
naught point eight percent of the global
economy that's just less than the drugs
trade or piracy
if cyber crime were a country its
economy would rank 27th in the world
higher than Singapore Austria and South
Africa the UK ranked 5th in the g20
countries most affected where 6.8
billion pounds worse off each year and
the report says the online crime cost
150,000 jobs in Europe for individual
businesses cybercrime can be
catastrophic
critical power suppliers in Oxfordshire
lost 20,000 pounds to a cyberattack
money that wasn't insured
it was the most soul-destroying thing in
five years of running a business to
happen terrifying luckily we actually
managed to have some reserves so we drew
on our reserves to keep the business
going but if you are a cash-strapped
business as many businesses are today
because this recession it would just
destroy you overnight cybercrime is no
back-alley affairs the gigantic industry
87% of all businesses suffered a breach
last year from large corporations to
family-run companies scale of the
problem is so vast it's impossible for
any one government to handle alone
I don't think any country can really do
this alone I think that law enforcement
agencies and nation-states do need to
come together in this particular area of
crime it's quite unique in reality and
criminals do not need to turn up in the
location in order to commit the crime
it's not like a murder or a drug
trafficking where somebody has to turn
up an hour
actually do it criminals are carrying
out and cyber crimes and they are doing
it from the safety of their own bedrooms
unlike their colleagues on the streets
the thin blue digital line now stretches
across the globe but is under ever more
strain Tom Cheshire Sky News